[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the michigan wolverines play villanova
later on tonight sweet 16. we had chris
webber on yesterday and we were talking
about michigan's run i looked at his
bracket and then uh i realized he didn't
pick michigan his alma mater to win the
national championship we spoke to jajuan
howard after the
show yesterday and we recorded an
interview and i started out by asking
him
did he know that uh chris webber did not
pick them to win the championship
no i do not share that with me please
houston
oh
it's a good team
impressive
yeah but great coach you had him in the
locker room he's given a pep talk to
your team and he didn't even pick you
guys to win the national championship
well i mean i'm sure chris is not the
first person that did not pick us
he would not be the only person that
does not pick us
did you pick michigan to win the
national championship at the start of
the tournament
i will tell you this
i trust with our staff and players since
july 1st
that we will be prepared for this moment
but if i told you a month ago
that you would be in this situation get
ready to take on villanova realistically
what would you have said
we are for competitors only
we're looking forward to the match-up
and so now we're here today
and
we are for competitors only and we're
looking forward to this
exciting game on thursday it's gonna be
a very competitive game on thursday i
mean they're a great team
well coach hall of fame coaching jeff
jay wright
won two national championships and by
the way one of those games was against
michigan so
um
they broke our hearts man
how do you
do you have your pep talk ready
all right no i do not
it's you know when you have a pep talk
you speak from the heart you know
i've always like whenever there's a
coach to try to give a pep talk and he
started looking at a paper
or
uh he started like you know it just
flows just naturally like uh you can
tell he practiced that
peptide's gotta come from the heart he's
gotta feel through the moment of passion
do you remember a particular pep talk
that you got
in college yeah you speak enough yeah
i'm too old man i got two minutes right
here
i can't recall
did you ever get a pep talk in the nba
did a coach ever give pep talks
oh yeah
i think that's what i'm you know
speaking at like some of those pep talks
in the nba
from some coaches and i'm not naming you
but you can tell which ones were you
know authentic and real and you know
the ones that was just
um
let's just get through the season guys
[Laughter]
um
you know it feels like
you've had a
i guess a roller coaster ride this year
how would you describe this uh this
season
well this season for all schools has
been dealt with diversity uh we dealt
with diversity through first starting
with injuries
secondly we had uh
guys key guys that missed games because
of covet
we also dealt with diversity through my
suspension um
and now we're here and that's just been
a test of character throughout our group
on uh you know we always talk about what
we are michigan family and you know and
when family go through things you know
families sometimes can either grow apart
or get stronger this family has
truly have been together and gotten
stronger what did you do when you were
suspended
well for me i did a lot of reflecting on
how i can improve as a person as a
player i'm sorry if you're not a player
as a coach
sometimes you still think yourself as a
player because you play in so many uh
high pressure games competitive games
and pressure moments but
and then with that you know this
counseling where and we'll continue to
keep going through counseling once the
season is over on
how i can help grow this team and how i
can be a better leader and that's
i think you know during that time i've
learned a lot
grew and i've gotten stronger while
doing it during that five game uh
absence
but did you recognize that guy
when you
like that yourself
when you watch the the video of that
against the wisconsin
well reflecting back on that situation
it was a tough moment it was a very
painful moment
um and
looking you know
and now getting back to that situation
and never want to go back to a moment
like that ever again and i grew from it
and uh
and with that um
you know i apologize for it
and now it's time to move on well
sometimes somebody needs a slap and
somebody needs a hug though juwan
[Laughter]
i need a hug
okay when you when you go up to the
tennessee kid
i mean when did you know that he needed
a hug after that loss
well you know kennedy you know very
competitive young man super talented and
as we're shaking you know
all the players hands and coaches
um you know i noticed where he he had a
cheerful moment and
that was a time as as a father also as a
coach
uh i felt he needed me and
i embraced them
try to give him some words of
encouragement encouragement and then
just at the end of the day just console
them and
i'm sure my my kids don't have a moment
like that someday and it'll be nice for
a coach to do the same for them too
well we talked to chris webber about the
time out that he called against north
carolina and and you know in the huddle
and you know he's he's emotional i mean
those are teaching moments he says he
goes i'm still teaching people about it
and i'm the one that went through it i
mean
that you got to witness that firsthand
yes uh you know that was you know
a very painful moment for the team
but also was more painful for chris
and
i never forget we're in a press
conference and
chris was blaming himself on our team's
loss
and you know i i had to interrupt him
during that moment and let him know that
you know as a team i would win together
and as a team we lose together and i
there was never you know a time where i
thought that that loss was you know
chris's loss you know and he was the you
know the reason why we lost that ball
game
um and it was nice to know that you know
he has grown from it um he's also has
helped others and just like how he
helped kennedy doing at that time it
just shows his level of where his heart
is and also his level of maturity i
think it was great you had him in the
locker room because i
thank you i think he loved it i mean i i
think it i think it hit him pretty hard
well you know uh that was the first time
chris has been back to a basketball game
uh and and then to have your brother who
guy who i've been in the trenches with
uh the guy who i've
a young teenager uh at the university of
michigan and uh we experience
experienced a lot of you know fun
moments
and a lot of teachable moments and we
also have grown together as brothers uh
and
we're family for a lifetime and to have
one of your brothers in the locker room
to support uh not just me you know
because it wasn't about me it was about
the players and the staff and um and to
leave you know his family to be present
uh i thought that was a very special
moment ray jackson calls him the black
unicorn
they call him the black leprechaun
he says that he never leaves the house
that you know you never see him right
yeah yeah i mean ray is classy man you
know like only ray can say something
like that uh to chris and get away with
it
uh you will advance if what
we take care of the basketball
we defend
without fouling
um
we
we don't get bored with the little
things that does not show up in a box
score
getting up on shot fakes
blocking out when they're they're
sprinting in for offensive rebounds
because you know elizabeth talked about
their shooting
and about you know how well they shoot
the ball from the free throw line
but
being a team that is tough and well
coached as villanova they do an
excellent job of getting second shot
opportunities so we're going to box out
and limit them to one shot opportunities
could you give me five minutes
like could you play five minutes
i can give you five minutes half court
oh so you would even you wouldn't run
down the other end
i wouldn't i wouldn't run down the other
end
and then i prefer to be on the offensive
side of course you do of course you do
uh hey congrats so far good luck against
villanova and uh we'll uh we'll be
watching
thank you dad thanks for having me
that's juwan howard tonight it'll be
michigan villanova arkansas gonzaga
texas tech duke houston in arizona